il faut qu'il pleuve encore une fois
toutes les deux semaines pour que le maïs germe.
Ensuite, il doit pleuvoir toutes les trois semaines
pour que les feuilles se forment,
alors que pendant la floraison, il faut qu'il pleuve plus souvent,
environ tous les 10 jours, pour que les épis se forment.
A la fin de la saison,
il ne faut plus qu'il pleuve,
car les pluies peuvent alors endommager les récoltes.
Cela est déjà compliqué de mettre au point une telle couverture
mais cela a été bien plus compliqué
de vendre ces assurances.
Après notre première saison,
nous avions le modeste objectif d'assurer 500 fermiers.
Au bout de deux mois de démarchage intense,
nous avions enregistré au total 185 fermiers.
J'étais déçue et déconcertée.
Tout le monde me disait que
les fermiers voulaient être assurés, mais...
les principaux intéressés n'achetaient pas.
Ils attendaient de voir ce qui allait se passer,
ne faisaient pas confiance aux compagnies d'assurance,
ou pensaient : « Je me suis débrouillé seul
pendant tant d'années, pourquoi aurais-je besoin d'une assurance ? »
Beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent sans doute
le microcrédit, qui permet aux plus pauvres d'emprunter,
mis en place par Muhammad Yunus,
qui a reçu le prix Nobel
pour son travail avec la Banque Grameen.
Mais il s'avère que vendre des micro-crédits,
n'est pas la même chose que de vendre des assurances.
Pour le crédit, le fermier doit gagner la confiance de la banque,
et s'il réussit, la banque lui prête de l'argent.
C'est un marché intéressant.
En ce qui concerne les assurances, le fermier doit d'abord
faire confiance à la compagnie d'assurance
et doit avancer de l'argent, à celle-ci.
Ce qui est complètement différent.
C'est pourquoi l'engouement pour s'assurer a été lent,
avec à ce jour seulement 4,4% d'Africains
couverts en 2012,
et la moitié d'entre eux se concentrent en Afrique du Sud.
Pendant des années, nous avons
essayé de vendre les assurances
directement aux fermiers, moyennant des coûts
exorbitants pour un résultat médiocre.
Nous avons réalisé que les fermiers
travaillaient avec de nombreuses organisations :
les entreprises de semences, les organismes de microfinance,
les compagnies de téléphonie mobile, les agences gouvernementales.
Toutes faisaient des prêts aux fermiers,
et souvent, juste avant de signer le contrat,
le fermier demandait :
« Que se passerat-il s'il ne pleut pas ?
Comment ferai-je pour rembourser le prêt ? »
La plupart de ces organisations prenaient le risque à leurs dépens
espérant simplement que cette année-là,
le pire ne se produirait pas.
Cependant, la plupart d 'entre elles
limitaient leurs investissements,
ils ne pouvaient pas prendre ce genre de risque.
Ces organisations sont devenues nos clients,
et en associant le crédit et l'assurance,
cela devient très intéressant.
Laissez-moi vous raconter encore une histoire.
Dans l'ouest du Kenya, au début de l'année 2012,
les pluies ont commencé à tomber très tôt,
ce qui a encouragé les fermiers, parce que
les pluies précoces annoncent une bonne année.
Alors ils ont emprunté et semé.
Pendant 3 semaines,
il n'y a pas eu une seule goutte de pluie,
les semences qui avaient si bien germé,
se sont inclinées et ont séché.
Nous avions assuré les prêts accordés pour 6000 fermiers de la région.
On leur a dit qu'on savait pour la sécheresse
et qu'ils recevraient 200 000 euros à la fin de cette saison.
Ils nous ont dit : « C'est super, mais ce sera trop tard.
Pourriez-vous nous donner de l'argent maintenant ? »
Comme ça, ils pourraient replanter et avoir une récolte, dès cette saison.
Alors nous avons convaincu nos partenaires de la société d'assurance
et les fermiers ont pu replanter.
Nous avons exposé cette idée à une société de semence
et les avons convaincus d'inclure le prix de l'assurance
dans celui des sacs de semences,
et dans chaque sac, nous avons placé une carte avec un numéro.
Quand les fermiers le trouvaient ils devaient nous envoyer un texto,
ce qui nous aidait à localiser le fermier grâce au satellite.
Le satellite mesurait alors les prévisions de pluie
pour les 3 semaines à venir, et s'il ne pleuvait pas,
nous remplacions les semences.
L'un des premiers -
(applaudissements) - attendez ! je n'ai pas encore fini !
L'un des premiers bénéficiaires de cette garantie de re-semence
était Bosco Mwinyi.
Nous lui avons rendu visite au mois d'août de cette même année
et vous auriez dû voir son sourire, quand il nous a montré la récolte
qui nous chauffait le cœur et qui m'a fait comprendre
que vendre des assurances pouvait être une bonne chose.
Puis, il a insisté pour que toute la récolte rentre dans la photo,
on a dû prendre du champ.
Les assurances lui ont permis d'assurer la récolte,
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui, nous avons les outils nécessaires
pour que les fermiers d'Afrique aient le contrôle sur leur destinée.
Plus d'année du « gobelet ».
A la place, je voudrais qu'on parle
d'une année de l'assurance,
ou de l'année de la grande récolte.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)